uh are you vexed
one shot in
i'm half i'm half a vaccine because uh i
finally i didn't want to do it okay i
was just holding out okay fake cards
fake cards fake cards
can i say one thing they had the health
inspector come to the seller right just
the health inspectors just going around
and selling he's like checking napkins
and [ __ ] like that like you know bottles
of bleach making sure they have
everything and chrissy just walks up
news hey what do you do here he's like
on the health inspector goes i got vax
carts for 300 if you need something
yeah the health inspector
was like oh
i know
liz texted me from the seller she's like
you [ __ ] idiot i was like i'm kidding
but for real
no but then you know
my see the thing is with me
is my i go by my daughter's uh
godfather's an er doctor yeah yeah and
so he was telling me he was like look
dude there you go he's like look dude
i'm not you know me man i'm never gonna
ever tell you what to do i haven't told
you [ __ ] what to do yeah he's like but
just like he's like it's just starting
to get bad again he's like nothing's
gonna happen to you even if you got
kovid he was like but i'm telling you
you're not gonna be able to do anything
unless you just get this [ __ ] dumb
shot oh so he was like you're just not
gonna be able to do anything right he
was like i promise you the restrictions
are gonna start to comfort people you
you the fake shit's not gonna work
anymore you're gonna have to get digital
there's you're gonna have no way around
it so i just got one about my you know
family like my mom and dad got it but
like my girl yeah she was like screaming
at me that i wouldn't get like get the
[ __ ] out of walgreens do not get that
shot do not get that shot and then i was
but i just got the first one and then
she was like convinced i was gonna die
but so far it's like four or five days
and i feel fine i mean good i feel
relatively fine i mean you know what am
i gonna do my me the fact my friend my
group chat like you know we had like
nine guys in the group
he's he's cannot believe what an idiot i
am yeah
he just can we call him real quick no
he's actually i was actually texting him
this morning he's working he's at the
firehouse yeah um so he's honest
yeah dude he he cannot believe that i
got it my friends are
furious that i got it but you know what
am i gonna you're leaning in right like
you you move to staten island like
you're going all in like i've retreated
yeah dude
i saw
i saw that the enemy was you know come
and come and coming so i said you know
what we're going to retreat over this
bridge right right this is where we'll
regroup
um but it was nice it's nice to be the
enemy
the chinese taking over
they said he's taking over you know what
it's so funny the chinese for whatever
reason they won't come over that bridge
really
yep staten island is starting to feel
staten island now because it used to be
because my ball paul my boy paulie who i
box with he calls his house the alamo
yeah that's what he calls his house
because he calls his house the alamo
because he lives he lives on 14th avenue
in bensonhurst brooklyn yeah and that
used to be an all-italian neighborhood
but now it's chinese and he's like this
is the alamo because we got the chinese
attacker from all sides
but i kind of feel like going over the
verrazano bridge on staten island yeah
they just know they just know you can't
do it yeah it's just and you know what
it is you know what you know what staten
island is it's kind of like that old
new york where it's like there's a
there's a it's still like a melting pot
of people yeah but you're still gonna
have like you know what it like that
upbringing out there like you know most
of the wives don't work you know like
even stat you know like when you go into
neighborhoods now in new york even
before let me tell you what staten
island is this is the first way you
described it most of the wives don't
work
it's just a lot of fun
and you know what if maybe now with the
pandemic fine but like before that
before the pandemic like you you go down
the street at staten island you know on
a [ __ ] monday tuesday wednesday yeah
at 10 a.m there's nobody there because
everybody's at work but you go to these
other neighborhoods it's like everyone's
on a laptop sitting in a coffee shop
there's no coffee shops on staten island
it's like what do you [ __ ] mean yeah
it's like you know it's just it's just
greek diners and you know starbucks and
[ __ ] but everybody for the most part is
at work which i like like i'm you know
i'm the gay one that i have like a
career in entertainment i want to make
like a podcast studio in my garage
but the guys will come over and do it
you know
i have to hire a builder for you oh 100
but like when i
i mean i hired people to paint my house
like paint the interior of my house and
the guys were like abusing me the whole
time to my girl and family even my
little daughters they're like you can't
paint the house yeah
and i was like i was like no i can but i
just want to be done right he's like yo
he's like and then one of the guys like
said to jasmine she was like can you
paint you should paint the house she was
like i would paint the house but he
wants you know to pay for us to paint
the house and he's like man he goes they
don't make them like they used to
anymore huh and then he was like what do
you do and i was like i'm a you know i i
do comedy and he was like yeah i never
heard of you
i was like yeah no i know i was like you
know i have like a younger crowd and
then he calls his like son or nephew
whatever who is 24 years old he goes
what's your name i said kristen stefano
he goes you ever hear of him and the kid
goes no now on speakerphone i was like
all right well you know [ __ ] it i mean
i'm not for everybody i guess
you know
but look dude i think the move is
successful you're happy down there i am
well i mean you know listen i can't
the thing is is like one you know i was
telling him before he came in it's like
once you have kids like your just
priorities got to change yeah it's like
i can't listen to some of our peers you
know in the west village talking to me
about the economy and the vaccine and
i'm like dude i don't you have six
roommates yeah i don't know what you're
[ __ ] talking about dude like you're
are you even i don't are you even in
society i gotta put my kids through
school the verrazano bridge is
effectively my wall so
i have it up so i'm just like i have to
keep my kids safe and and and all that
and you know look dude i think i think
most parents yeah you know we're just
like we look at the world a little
differently we're like yeah okay look
i'm gonna get the vaccine i'm not gonna
give it to my kid i'm not gonna get i
but i figured as a parent if they're
gonna make me eventually give it to my
kid i at least gotta get it first and
just you know see what happens what was
the celebration like in staten island
when the medal count
moved to the us's favor
so
why we took out china
i would say 39 38 during the final day
listen i'll tell you what it was big but
it wasn't as big as when italy won the
world cup so that's what won the euro
cup i meant to say when italy won the
euro cup i that we will staten island
will celebrate italian victories more
than they'll celebrate united states
victories but when they won that when
they won that euro comp holy [ __ ] it was
crazy over there oh this is interesting
so didn't
italians
quote unquote steal pasta from the
chinese yeah that's what they say
macaroni spaghetti yeah now is it
possible the chinese are just coming to
take it back
listen
maybe i don't i don't necessarily hate
chinese food i just can't use chopsticks
i don't know how to use their utensils
why because you have the thumb the other
thing i've got the thumb [ __ ] and i
don't know i just rather just use a fork
you know what i mean but they get upset
about so that's like a really fun like
american thing to do i don't know how to
use these [ __ ] things yeah
what is this i joke about it i've said
this joke on stage but it's like
genuinely true my grandfather has been
dead for 15 years now but he really i
mean in the 90s wouldn't would not eat
sushi
because because he's still considered
japan the enemy because he fought in
world war ii i'll never forget i
remember we were in the car and my
mother was like what do you guys want
for lunch and i was like you know
whatever i said on my mom's like i feel
like sushi you know she said dad what
about a bento box he was like are you
kidding me lin not after what they did
at the harbour
just kept driving mcdonald's
you